[Music]
so the EU is negotiating a new trade and
investment agreement with the US it's a
big deal in many ways and yes it affects
you that's the whole idea the
transatlantic trade and investment
partnership or ttip would cut costs for
business and prices for consumers
without cutting
Corners the eu's high standards
protecting our health safety rights at
work privacy Financial Security and
environment are front and center
throughout the T tip
process we've heard the rumors about
imported chlorinated chicken hormon
treated beef Vamp and garlic All Pure
Fantasy we understand a big project like
this raises concerns about standards
we'll uphold them not undermine them and
we want to deal but not at any
price we're listening we do get it learn
more about ttip and have your
say